CHRISTOPHER SANSON: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see CI/CD
in a Serverless World,
then stay tuned, because
here's the Rewind.
The development ecosystem is
always changing for companies
as they look to grow and
scale their businesses.
Continuous integration and
continuous delivery, or CI/CD,
has become an essential
process for helping
teams deliver code changes
more frequently and reliably.
Thanks to increases in
serverless technology,
teams can build and
deploy their code
with even more
speed and structure.
First, let's define what
we mean by serverless.
The core idea here is
that we're able to focus
on running our application
code without having
to worry about
the infrastructure
or the underlying logic used to
run or scale our application.
Serverless options are
increasing in popularity
and tools around these are still
evolving and growing rapidly.
In fact, Google has had a number
of serverless offerings going
as far back as App Engine,
which released 10 years ago.
All of these cover a
wide variety of services,
but for CI/CD, we'll
mainly be focusing
on compute offerings such as
App Engine or Cloud Functions.
So when looking
at CI/CD, there's
a whole bunch of things like
build agents and configuration
management that we
would need to deal
with in a legacy environment.
Instead of jumping through hoops
and managing the infrastructure
for all of these, let's focus
on embracing serverless concepts
and best practices.
By doing this, we can
reduce our overhead
and spend more time
on our application.
Serverless lets us focus
on making our deployments
automatic, faster, and safer.
By really drilling into the
automated tasks and process,
our code can quickly go
from commit to deployed.
And we're able to customize
build steps such as testing
and manual approval.
To capture all the benefits of
coding in a serverless world,
we can configure tasks and
deployment strategies as needed
such as blue green and canary.
For all the processes
we've just outlined,
we need to tool
to manage all the
traveling that our
code needs to do,
and that's where
Cloud Build comes in.
This is a pretty
typical workflow,
and Cloud Build helps
improve developer velocity
and manage the build steps
like packaging and testing,
deploying to staging, and
reviewing it before finally
promoting it into production.
Whew!
Cloud Build is also
serverless and highly
configurable with built-in
support for CLI tools,
encryption for API secrets,
and local build support.
Whether building on
VMs or serverless,
a well-structured
CI/CD pipeline lets
us benefit from automation.
Cloud Build helps us create
the rules of the system
and get all the
efficiencies without having
to worry about any of the
details of the infrastructure.
In the talk, Christopher
Sanson takes us
through a demonstration
of his new Prepster
Shop built on App Engine,
Firebase, and Cloud functions.
I definitely recommend
checking it out
to see all the features
of Cloud Build in action
and how it really enables
CI/CD in a serverless world.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.